on constate véritablement qu'il y a une
course à qui séduira les électeurs de
gauche c'est qu'il y a toujours l'idée
derrière son propos que plus rien ne
sera jamais comme avant il y a quand
même un enjeu monstrueux pour Emmanuel
il ne veut pas être le président qui a
perdu contre l'extrême droite
je débattrai avec Marine Le Pen comme je
l'ai fait il y a 5 ans
mais j'ai hâte de deux d'expliquer de
d'abord de lever les contre-vérités qui
sont installées
en campagne moi ça fait 30 semaines il y
a pas de match ça n'existe pas et là
c'est un match de boxe parce qu'ils sont
deux il y a un ring ils vont se rendre
compte c'est sûr il a hâte d'aller en
campagne pourquoi la nature a horreur du
vide vous le savez la politique c'est
pareil quand vous ne parlez pas c'est
tout bon qui parle à votre place ce qui
te frappant dans la passe d'armes entre
Emmanuel Macron et Marine Le Pen c'est
qu'on assiste véritablement à ce que les
Américains appellent une campagne
négative c'est à dire que on n'a pas de
candidats qui vont défendre uniquement
leurs projets ils vont avant tout
essayer de démolir l'autre elle avait le
plus sur la personne d'Emmanuel Macron
et lui mettre plus sur le programme donc
déjà on a deux armes complètement
différentes à mes prix un dédain les
gars des Français il ne faut pas
simplement suivre le vent être dans la
démagogie depuis 5 ans Emmanuel Macron a
mené une politique extrêmement dur alors
c'est pas quelque chose qui est
forcément nouveau dans l'univers
politique car on sait par exemple que
lors du débat origan Carter en 80 l'un
des tournants pendant le débat ça avait
été vraiment une question posée par
Ronald Reagan qui était est-ce que vous
pensez vivre mieux qu'il y a 4 ans
finalement dans ce type de campagne la
réfutation de la crédibilité de l'autre
vient avant l'argumentation de son
propre programme que je suis fier
d'avoir porté en votre nom et à vos
côtés et qui me fait un peu m'énerver à
mépris ressenti comme une véritable
souffrance mais là on est véritablement
sur de la dominem finalement sur sur de
la personne il y a du rejet de la
personne on voit bien que c'est pas une
campagne politique c'est une campagne
émotionnelle c'est un grand casting tu
ne dois pas être d'incarnation Marine Le
Pen et la grasse aux émotions qu'elle a
procure en français on va leur absolue
Le Pen 2022 c'est ça 95 avec les
couteaux
c'est quand ils se retourner au guignol
il y a plein de poignards mais il y
avait c'est quand même une dague de trop
la dague de trop c'est celle de Mario
maréchal ce qui veut dire que elle est
rentrée pour la première fois de sa
carrière pour la première fois de
l'histoire de l'Open dans le cœur des
Français
[Musique]
le 24 avril
si les Français ont affaire barrage 7 au
retour d'Emmanuel Macron
et je n'oublie pas ce que Madame Le Pen
a aussi dit constamment pendant la crise
du covid elle allait soigner les gens à
la chloroquine elle a les vacciner
massivement avec un vaccin russe dont
même l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé
a déclaré qu'il n'était pas efficace et
à la critiqué à ces méthodiquement
toutes les décisions prises par le
gouvernement sans lesquelles nous
n'aurions pas tenu
souvent en fait Emmanuel Macron fait
référence à Marine Le Pen non pas par
son nom mais comme étant la candidate de
l'extrême droite pour essayer de
susciter une réaction de rejet entre le
projet que je défends et celui de la
candidate d'extrême droite les choses
sont claires
la candidate d'extrême droite propose un
projet nationaliste ce qui n'est pas le
patriotisme 5 ans ou Emmanuel Macron si
par malheur il était réélu se sentirait
totalement libre d'aller au bout de la
politique de sa cage social qu'il a
entamé lors de son premier mandat au
bout de la perte de souveraineté de
notre pays au bénéfice de quelques-uns
et au détriment du plus grand nombre
disons que maintenant qu'il est dans son
deuxième et dernier quinquennat il va
réformer mais à tout va et donc elle
fait peur que la réforme c'est dangereux
pour eux donc on voit bien que la
rhétorique en fait entre les deux c'est
aussi un combat d'imposer ces
définitions ces deux figures qui
reviennent assez régulièrement c'est
l'effet de répétition et l'appel à la
flatterie non mais je compte sur tous
les électeurs français je compte sur
leur lucidité je compte sur leur
intelligence je compte sur leur capacité
à prendre conscience qu'on ne peut pas
continuer 5 ans de plus dans cette
situation on a cet appel à la flatterie
qui est martelé et qui revient souvent
alors avec un bémol qui est quand même
que le français n'est intelligent que
s'il est d'accord avec elle c'est la
toute la ruse en fait de l'appel à la
flatterie car le sujet flatté ne l'est
que tant qu'il se soumet à son flatteur
c'est un petit peu comme dans le corbeau
et le renard si on voulait on distrait
les gens et on les pousse à l'adhésion
par le biais de l'éloge et des louanges
les candidats devront rassembler les
Français devront séduire les Français
devront rassurer les Français et on peut
pas le faire uniquement quand je tombe
sur l'eau toutes les fautes là Macron
utilise aussi quelque chose qu'il
faisait souvent c'est qu'il y a toujours
l'idée derrière son propos que plus rien
ne sera jamais comme avant avec de
manière sous-jacente peut-être une
tentative de donner un petit peu
d'optimisme c'est ça qui va faire
pendant 15 jours pourquoi parce qu'il
doit élargir que élargir à ceux qui ou
une mauvaise image de lui qui en a
priori ça fait 5 ans que je suis
président et je regarde aussi les
fractures qu'il y a dans le pays et les
colères et donc je veux élargir sans
ambiguïté je sais qu'il y a des gens qui
voteront pour moi ou qui s'abstindon
pour faire barrage au Front national ça
veut pas dire qu'ils soutiendront de mon
projet mais je veux essayer de
convaincre des gens de faire avec moi et
donc peut-être en effet de de compléter
mon projet d'aller plus loin Emmanuel
Macron du peuple c'est un artifice
électoral somnifère à destination des
électeurs de gauche à qui cherche à
faire prendre des vessies pour des
lanternes clarifier cette ligne avec une
planification écologique qui pourra
mettre si je puis dire année après année
ces objectifs mais je pense que la
méthode est bonne notre système de
protection sociale et bien je souhaite
moi le préserver parce que je considère
que le système de protection sociale
c'est le bien de ceux qui n'en n'ont pas
c'est le patrimoine de ceux qui n'en
n'ont pas très certainement un certain
nombre d'électeurs de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
peuvent être intéressés par cette
protection que je leur offre des appels
du pied il y a que ça clairement on
constate véritablement qu'il y a une
course à qui séduira les électeurs de
gauche donc là on a un appel du pied qui
est clairement assez peu subtil ou on
cite directement les concerner en
sachant tout de même que lors de sa
rentrée 2017 Marine Le Pen avait traité
la France insoumise de bouillie
idéologie là voilà il y a du chemin qui
a été parcouru depuis celle qui a aussi
sur le grand remplacement c'est Marine
Le Pen c'est pourquoi parce qu'elle a
remplacé la Marine Le Pen de 2017 en la
nouvelle Marine Le Pen 2022 et elle a
complètement remplacé ce qu'elle était
pour l'instant il y a toujours eu ce
fond républicain
sauf que là cette année c'est Marine Le
Pen qui a inventé à fond qui Macron il
faut républicain pour l'instant il y en
a pas donc Emmanuel Macron est
extrêmement concentré parce que d'être
dans l'histoire le président qui aura
permis Alexandra de venir au pouvoir ça
c'est pas possible
[Musique]